YouTube is now banning comments on most
videos featuring minors to protect them
from child predators this comes after
reports that predators were allegedly
using YouTube's comment section to share
timestamps of when children were in
compromising positions
YouTube CEO Susan Wojcicki you tweeted
yesterday nothing is more important to
us than ensuring the safety of young
people on the platform the company said
it disabled comments from tens of
millions of videos it is also working on
a new system to better detect and remove
predatory comments wired senior writer
and CBS News contributor se lapowski is
here good morning morning so what do you
make of this move well I think YouTube
is making a pretty strong statement that
this predatory behavior has no place on
the YouTube platform remember YouTube's
entire ballgame is generating engagement
it's getting people to watch videos it's
getting people to comment on them so
this is a big business move for them
they say that it's gonna take months to
roll out to suspend all these comments
because of course they have to first
identify the videos that are at risk for
these kinds of comments so it's a really
big deal and a number of companies have
already pulled ads correct absolutely
AT&T has pulled adds Hasbro has told
some companies some reporters that they
pulled ads so obviously this is not just
the public outcry but there's there's
outcry from from YouTube's advertisers
they can take a small hit but they need
to do something fast there have been a
number of reports that there are videos
with very popular children's characters
like Peppa the Peppa the pig I should
know this more my son is not old enough
to watch Peppa the pig but Peppa the pig
is hugely popular and there are reports
that there's obscene content in those
videos what what can parents do Peppa
the pig minecraft it's a lot of really
popular children's franchises and this
is content that's basically masquerading
as kids content but then it glorifies
suicide or school shootings it's really
scary stuff so steps parents can take
first step is go to YouTube kids YouTube
kids offers a lot more parental controls
than the YouTube main app on YouTube
kids you can pick trusted channels that
YouTube has selected so think PBS or
Sesame Workshop parents can also create
their own customized lists so you know
what your kids like to watch on what
they're gonna be
begging you to watch so you can create
that list of channels and approved
videos you can turn off search ability
and you can set a passcode so that you
know older smarter kids aren't able to
override your settings you can also set
these settings on based on the age of
your children you can create different
profiles for your children so parents do
need to be a little bit proactive here
because there's really scary stuff out
there now passports and codes are key
can you address this this Momo challenge
and whether or not this is hoax or if
it's actually real and it is this online
concern that children are being
encouraged to hurt themselves right it's
a hoax it's a hoax it's a hoax I can't
say it enough the more we talk about it
tends to give oxygen to this kind of
thing this is you know started as a
viral hoax intended to worried parents
intended to get people talking about it
but YouTube has said and and reporters
have found there's no evidence that
children are actually taking action on
these videos or that these videos are
even really spreading in any kind of way
but that's not to say that there isn't
risk out there that there aren't videos
that are glorifying suicide and that are
targeted to kids so as we talked about
parents need to take these precautions
if it's not against Momo there's a lot
of other stuff out there that you need
to be cautious of how quickly can you to
clean up something like this because
they've had various issues over time
advertisers have been nervous they've
said they're gonna is it possible to
sort of dispense with this quickly get
the advertisers back or is this a really
labor-intensive well they by their own
admission it's gonna take them months to
address this common issue because you
think about how tough this is YouTube
tries to address a lot of this stuff
with algorithms right and algorithms
know how to how to find sexually
explicit content or violent graphic
violence but a lot of these time stamps
a lot of these comments appear benign in
isolation it's only when you match them
up to the videos themselves that you
realize really how sinister they are so
this is a whole new learning experience
for YouTube so they're working on their
algorithms rolling them out to try to
find this stuff a lot faster so the last
question I don't have to watch all these
videos with my kids then right steps are
being made and taken to make sure what
our kids are watching are safe I think
that you should still you know monitor
your kids watch history make sure that
you know what channels they're
watching I don't think you have to watch
every one of these videos and they are
taking those steps but there's no
replacement for our parents items
there's so much only so much Peppa can
take me feel fast me thank you so much
great to have you on